hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game that features uh an even
greater move uh from 1914 it was played
in italy between doctor zigbert
and uh well uh if you've seen this game
for example if you've read about it in
old books uh it's always uh uh titled as
a zigberthara versus the allies but it's
actually
the allies are known people uh and the
the strongest of the allies was david
marotti who will later
become italian champion 1921 and he's
also a professor of literature
and philosophy i i don't know if he was
at the time the game was played but he
did become one
uh later on but the other three
gentlemen that joined david marotti in
his
uh well uh quest for victory against
zigberg tarash
the simon and del judis i don't know if
i've pronounced that correctly as it is
uh
italian uh but it's a one against four
but always when you have like uh
if one person plays against uh a hundred
people
you will always most likely played the
moves that the strongest of them
suggests which in this case is david
marotti
uh so i think most of the moves uh are
his i imagine i don't know
i don't think they had like uh let's
each play one move
now while i'm showing this game i've
seen it many times i've seen
it uh when i first started uh learning
about chess also
from books and this this is a very
famous game so uh of course it's
featured in a lot of them and uh
i never knew what the what the well what
the actual
uh so-called chess device here in this
game uh used was called and it's
actually called a placehuta
now uh just uh help you out with the
with the actual
uh word there is a prashutta uh and i've
never heard about this uh
well uh word or or the meaning
uh it's actually uh
okay we're gonna get uh we're gonna get
to it why why it's called that way and
what it means uh but basically uh it's
uh well let's let's just check out the
game and then when we reach the position
then we're going to discuss it
so like i said uh the game played in
italy in 1914 ziggler tarash versus the
allies uh but now you know who is uh
playing uh well board one for the allies
so to say
who uh that this is not a photo of him
from
when the when the game was played this
is a photo from 1922
so some eight years after the actual
game was played so he will look a bit
younger uh in this actual game but okay
uh here tarash opens with f4 he opens
with
the bird opening we have d5 and it's
actually a very nice game
uh sorry about that so grabbing the
center we have knight to f3 and
c5 so grabbing a lot of central squares
here with
e3 and now knight to c6
and bishop to b5 putting pressure on the
on the knight here bishop d7 continuing
development
and taras castle uh ataris castles we
have e6
and now b3 taras prepares the fianchetto
the dark square bishop we have queen to
c7
developing most likely preparing to
castle queenside as none of the king
side the pieces have been developed yet
and bishop to b2 and it's interesting
this position has never again been
reached uh in any other game so f6
uh making this bishop a a bit less
useful as now
uh it's kind of a kind of a problem uh
for this bishop and also you might be
interested in playing e5 sometimes in
the future so it
it will come in handy uh and here c4 by
white
uh now challenging this pawn and uh
white uh well black has to decide how to
deal with this as knight to c3 is coming
you're gonna have a lot of pressure here
on d5
so here knight e knight c to e7 uh
getting more defense to this d5 pawn and
also preparing to trade bishops here
we have knight to c3 nicely continuing
to pile up on the d5 pawn and now
knight to h6 now that this knight
occupies d7 square you have to find
how to develop this knight so knight h6
and now rook to c1
putting the rook on the same uh file as
the queen as if the position opens up
uh this could allow for some uh for some
nasty tactics so here
bishop captures on b5 we have knight
captures attacking the queen and the
queen d7 so this is probably
what the allies were going for to get
the queen uh
off of the or off of the c file
we have queen to e2 finally white
develops the queen connects the rooks
and now
knight to c6 getting the knight back as
the d5 pawn is
sufficiently defended and you also want
to put some pressure on
on d4 so here we have c
characters on d5 we have e captures
and e5 and now e4 and here
black has to decide what to do here it's
a problem because
you don't want to allow the position to
open up your king is still in the center
of the board so you have to react to
this
you could capture here for example
captures captures in bishop e7 but it
looks
uh it looks kind of weird you've opened
up the position your king is still here
in the center of the board so here we
have queen side castles
uh now getting the king to safety uh and
now
not capturing here but rather e5 if you
capture here you pretty much solve all
of black's problems
the queen is now nicely centralized and
you don't really have any
uh any any good moves here for white to
to to grab some initiative so instead
uh taras keeps the the center closed and
he goes for e5
and now okay uh the queen uh is not
centralized the queen is still on d7
and you are threatening to capture on f6
so what do you do here
uh king to b8 is always a nice
prophylactic move but black decides to
kick the knight away from this
active square so we have a6 attacking
the knight and knight back to c3
and now the very aggressive b5 and uh
well what do you do now with white black
is not afraid he
he started expanding on the queen side
as well and the white wants to attack on
the queen side so it's
it's good for both of them with a4
saying okay weirdo open up the a file or
you have to advance the pawn so b4 is
played and now
knight back to d1 uh as we all know the
strongest move uh
and the hardest one to find is the move
with the knight back so here
knight d1 uh the knight will be
remaneuvered to e3 and then later on
uh where black allows so here king to b7
now that the knight
was moved and this uh pawn has been
advanced to b4 the a6 pawn is hanging
so black needs to defend it we have king
to b7 and now
uh e captures an f6 uh it looks a bit uh
scary since uh the bishop can capture
here and attack both of the rooks but
black has
everything planned out or or so black
things
or rather so they think uh but after g
captures bishop characters now yes the
two rooks are under attack
but here comes rook e8 uh attacking
white's queen so you're not in time to
grab the rook on h8
uh with knight the e3 here white says
okay
you i don't have to worry about d4
because your rook is hanging
so here rook the g8 now
getting the the rook out of the way and
now queen to d3 not allowing d4 to trap
the knight
and now comes knight to g4 the problem
with the d for now
although it looks uh looks kind of
interesting is that you can just ignore
the pawn
play whatever you want and black cannot
capture as the queen would be hanging
so here we have knight to g4 now trying
to trade off knights to get the queen
into the attack but here
uh tarash does exactly that uh you
you might think okay you could grab the
d5 pawn but then after knight captures
an f6
the queen is actually defended so you
just blunder a piece
so here instead we have knight
characters on g4 queen captures now
threatening checkmate
and tarash defends with rook to f2 so
the g2 pawn is nicely defended and now
uh the d5 pawn needs to be defended so
queen back to d7
and now white needs to figure out a way
how to continue the attack we have
knight to e5
attacking the queen and here black
decides to trade we have captures on e5
bishop captures on e5 and now rook the
c8 as white is most likely to
uh try and uh do some pressure uh along
the c
file probably move the queen play d3
double up here and go after
after the the king so black also
prepares to defend against this
here queen to f3 uh the the strongest
move by far you have to make room for d3
to be played to get this rook over to c2
and black doesn't really have a a good
way of doing any attacking this bishop
and pawn
combo is a you know marvelous defensive
structure
and with the rook and f2 well basically
on the second rank regarding the g2 pawn
there's not much black can do
so here we have king to b6 adding
another defender to the c5 pawn here and
now
d3 d3 is a very nice move as it prevents
black from executing c4 at any point but
also you just want to play rook after c2
and put more pressure along the c
file so bishop to h6 now that the c5
pawn is
defended sufficiently black also tries
to develop uh
white will not be able to start pushing
the past f pawn as the rook is still on
c1
uh but white doesn't care uh white uh to
completely abandons the plan of pushing
the
s the past f pawn this is a very nice
defensive structure like we mentioned
so rook f the c2 and now uh now the
fun really starts here uh we have d4
there there could be some ideas of uh uh
maybe maybe like
capturing and then playing something
like bishop to d4 to pin the rook after
rook recaptures for the moment it's not
possible but
uh just to prevent all of that black
just goes d4
and now black says i don't have to worry
about this anymore uh there's no way for
you to capture and
my c5 pawn is defended sufficiently but
here
uh white finds a brilliant breakthrough
white plays a5 with
check and now the problem is uh you have
to play something problem is if you
capture the pawn
then you just get uh rook captures on c5
as the c5
rook is not defended captures captures
and after uh you
you move the king you just play rook to
c7 attack the queen and there is no
defense
black is completely busted here so what
actually happened after a5
check uh the allies decided to play king
to b5 but now
now uh we reach the position where the
uh let's uh bring it up
one more time where the prosciutta is
possible so
uh feel free to pause the video and uh
well find this
uh brilliancy that all almost never
occurs in actual play it's more of a
thing that you will find in in
uh you know constructed chess problems
uh or chess puzzles
uh but here it actually happened in an
actual game uh so feel free to pause the
video and find
this brilliant winning idea uh well i
give you a couple of seconds with best
defense
it's actually made in five uh so you
know uh
have at it
so uh for those of you uh who were able
to do it congratulations on solving your
first prashuta
and for those of you who already knew
the solution because this is a very
famous game
maybe maybe you just learned that this
was actually a prashuta
uh and well for everyone else uh the
move is
bishop to c7 and this is uh
wow i mean i i remember seeing this
movie in old books but i never really
gave it
this much thought uh because it's
brilliant
uh you block the queen's defense of the
b7 square
and now queen b7 is possible you also
block the rook's defense of the c5 pawn
and now uh rook captures on c5 becomes
possible
and now the plush it's a prosciutto uh
because
you've uh you've gave up a piece it also
works if you give up a pawn i've seen
some
puzzles where you give up on it's also
considered a prosciutto but i don't
i don't know they didn't seem uh as
impressive as when you give up a piece
so this bishop to c7 is uh one of the
nicest i've seen
there is also another one that i thought
was very impressive but
we might show that some other time but
here bishop the c7
incredible uh because uh whichever piece
captures the rook or the queen uh gets
in the way of the other piece
and that's just crazy it's it's also
possible like with the queen and the
bishop when they go on the same diagonal
or or with the two rooks that are
uh you know using the the same file to
to go for the piece
uh but here uh it doesn't work because
like i said okay queen b7 is possible
now
captures and c5 is possible but
capturing the bishop
is not possible because if queen
captures on c7
then you get the very nice rook captures
on c7 and now you can no longer guard
the b7 square queen has the capture and
now after
this check it's all over you have to
either play queen b6 and then just queen
captures his checkmate or you capture on
a5
and then rook to a1 is checkmate so
that's one way to go about it after
bishop to c7 but the queen doesn't have
to capture maybe the rook can capture
and then we also try something problem
is after rook captures
uh we get this brilliancy of queen to b7
check and now again there's not much to
do king captures on a5 runs into rook to
a1
check and that's not uh that's not uh
you know happening okay we can even show
it if you don't believe me rookie one
check
only move queen blocks and then rook
captures his checkmate so we're not
gonna
dwell too much on that uh however if
rook captures here then it's
the instant rook captures on c5
checkmate because now the rook
also covers the a5 square so uh really
this bishop the c7 move uh quite to the
brilliancy
uh show it to your friends at the bar in
the library they will be immensely
impressed by your great knowledge
and uh well the the third option of
course the one we have to check
uh okay if you can't capture with the
rook if you can't capture with the queen
must we capture it all uh yes uh because
if you don't
there's simply no move for you to play
what are you gonna play this is the
threat of checkmate you can't allow
queen to b7
like whatever you try here simply
doesn't work
and uh it would be pointless to even try
playing something here i i i even have
no idea
what you could play here so there really
isn't a move like
how do you how do you defend against
this you you simply don't
and there there's no other move for you
to play you you could drag this out
maybe
uh do some silly moves but that's i mean
that
that would be pointless so bishop the c7
uh it's uh it's almost magical how this
uh
how this move ends the game and this is
the let's show it for the third time
remember this is a prosciutto so you
know today when you're you know enjoying
your saturday with your friends not at
the bar
as you know the situation in the world
and everything uh tell them about
prosciutta
as it's uh you know uh i i you know i
learned the
term today myself even though i like uh
do chess stuff
uh quite often pretty much all the time
but i've never actually heard
the term even though i've seen this game
so it's always
always very enjoyable for me uh to learn
new stuff especially a new word i mean
how often do you learn a new word
uh but yeah like i said i will put uh
some useful
materials on the prosciutto in the
description below so you can check that
out
and yeah if you ever see this in a book
or somewhere uh zigbertharash versus the
allies you will know who the allies were
and uh yeah that's uh that's uh it for
this uh
the prosciutto so that's uh the
prosciutto
i do hope you guys enjoyed it i would
like to thank aryan delange uh pablo
mohan stephen hopps
neil costford and anandron for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching
and i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the
morphe saga checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens
in the chess world uh like the like the
the the new
uh magnus carlsen tournament that starts
tomorrow
so yeah uh thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day